I have to rush!
I promised to baby-sit my cousin, since my sister and brother-in-law are both working.
I don't have any problems with baby-sitting,...
...but I think it's better for the kid to spend as much time as possible with her parents.
Let's say, if one of them had to quit,...
...then I guess it's better for my sister to give up her career to look after the child.
Once you become a parent, a child's upbringing is just as important as a successful career.
Wow, you have very set ideas on bringing up children.
Well, here's what I think.
Traditionally, couples have been working for economic reasons.
Today, more and more people, especially women,...
...want to pursue their dreams and happiness by succeeding in their careers.
I think that is one major reason why there's an increasing number of married couples both working to make a living.
But when it comes to child nurturing and doing housework,...
...both husband and wife are responsible and shouldn't place the burden onto the other.
The one who has free time should be in charge.
Also, like what you are doing,...
...other family members could help with doing things like baby-sitting, or cleaning the house.
Hmm... That makes sense.